the Joe Rogan experience how many
[ __ ] orange challenges do you think
they needed to get for oh my god
so we name rekt one in every episode
that to me is one of the more
interesting episodes in our culture that
that show which was a beloved part of
our past is now taboo you will never
find it anywhere because the Confederate
flag on the roof and when we were kids
oh yeah that came over here it's [ __ ]
KKK it's racism it's white sheets it's
when we were kids it meant the south
yeah it didn't mean the same thing
there's a [ __ ] poster that I have
over the pisser from Leonard Skynyrd
concert from like set that sometime
during the 70s they have a giant
Confederate flag behind them backstage
yeah but it didn't mean they were racist
it meant they were from the south but
somewhere along the line it shifted this
is where the argument gets weird right
because people say hey it's not about
that it's about southern pride I
understand it used to be about southern
pride but now unfortunately that flag is
now connected to racism so you're
sending out a bad signal yeah so what
you want that flag to mean for you
that's great but what that flag means
for other people is now changed yeah and
you either accept that or you know
you're fighting against it oh you can't
get me the [ __ ] [ __ ] this means this
today but people don't they just they're
not think people have time to rationally
consider whether or not you're racist or
whether or not you're from the south
what are you why do you have that flag
you don't have time to consider that
they just go oh you must be in the KKK
oh you must hate black people Oh bang
there it is racist
you got that flag so some something
shifted like really radically and deduce
a hazard is like a great metric of it so
one of the great things in our culture
we could use to measure you know look
what happened you had a hit show then
literally sparked a type of clothing the
daisy dukes for gay men yeah and for
girls that are really sad like we see a
girl with davis daisy dukes like sweetie
you don't need that you're hot without
it oh he's kidding me so hard those days
you do
[Applause]